[Applaudissements]
je suis fier de moi la médaille la
coupe c'est juste une récompense suite
aux efforts fournis c'est un rêve et
voilà c'est devenu réalité on espère
encore faire beaucoup plus parce que
c'est ma carrière que je suis en TR de
construire et je dois encore donner plus
mon objectif c'est d'être d'abord
professionnel je rêve un jour d'aller
jouer en
Europe mêmeme en Asie c'est ça d'abord
mon objectif et comme on commence à
amener de telles opportunités vraiment
pour nous c'est une très bonne
chose
pousser joueurs à chercherégalisur
pourip
la équipe moi je suis très heureux parce
que il y a quelques années j'étais à
leur place j'ai eu la chance d'être
recrouté par l'AS Monaco de faire ma
carrière donc ce genre de tournoi ce
genre d'événement ça leur donne aussi
des rêve et nous aussi on est là pour
leur donner les outils pour que pour
qu'ils puissent se
projeter 4e
arbitre
équipe la face du monde a des à
[Musique]
faireoir en fait ça faisait déjà un
petit temps que je voulais que ces
enfants aient une une voix de sortie
parce que quand tu les entraînes tous
les jours et que tu dois leur inculquer
des valeurs et cetera à un moment donné
euh ton le discours peut arriver à à
épuisement si on a pas de de réelle
opportunité pour eux énormément de
jeunes qui ont été vu qui ont fait des
belles prestations il y en a quelquesuns
qui sont retenus je pense que d'ici peu
on va commencer cette le prolongement de
cette belle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
histoire